people make mistakes because when you do
that when you make a mistake you're
going to wish somebody granted you the
freaking leash to come back and
apologize and give it another go you're
not going to ask him about Sarah so we
know he's already on everybody remembers
and uh I forget maybe it was Mike or
someone said go yes about steroism of
course he is he's on obviously who the
[ __ ] I I was literally like of course he
is why would I ask him about that yeah
and then obviously
he says no so what do you well I'm just
gonna ruin this that's crazy like why do
you have to ask him you keep harping on
it yeah that's like Kim coming here
talking about my losses it's like wait
what are we doing you just want to talk
about [ __ ] I don't want to talk about I
don't want to do that and then you're
not getting a great interview because
then I shut down and I'm like oh you I
don't feel safe with you you're going
for click bait I don't feel safe now
you're not getting me being entertaining
any capacity